[Music]
attendance continues to be a concern in
our schools the school district
struggled to reach its goal in reducing
student absences last year the question
this year are things any better some
parents tell candace charles the first
day of school not a good sign candace
joined us live in studio to tell us why
families are blaming the district
yeah let's say class schedules not being
done student is not registered the list
goes on for a number of reasons students
are already missing school but district
is working to improve intended we were
very disappointed she was looking
forward to her first day at school
instead sabrina calisco's sister katie
keene was told to go home we were told
that her packet was ready she had
everything that she needed to be
registered in the school i just hadn't
been processed yet there are 295 000
students enrolled in the school district
with issues the first week of school
some were on the way to becoming a
chronic absentee student it only takes
missing 18 days or more to get the
designation katie already missed two
she's been sitting in the library into
her sixth period because they still had
not made her
a schedule some of the reasons students
missed school no class schedule to
shared housing issues did not explain
why it hadn't been processed they just
simply
said that
they were overwhelmed when we were in
line they were just sending kids home
left and right last year according to
ccsd the chronic absenteeism rate was
just shy of 34 percent a little higher
than the states and neighboring
districts johnson middle school where
katie attends sat at 51 percent the
result of all this missed class time
causing backlash for the district i
personally went to ccsd my sisters go to
ccsd my son will not be going to ccsd if
first week of school is this much of a
disaster
i'm not interested in putting my son in
ccsd
now a district representative told me
quote in general we are working on
things side by side with schools to
approve attendance it currently has 25
truancy officers but they couldn't give
me exact reasons or numbers on those
recent absences for now in the studio
i'm kandace charles 8 news now candace
thank you and in 2019 the district set a
goal in its five-year strategic plan to
reduce chronic absenteeism to 16 in 2024
the district continues to work towards
that goal